- no this is perfect muggers my like
superhero 101 well our work here is done
you ready to suit up oh I'm ready for my
super suit you stretchy it stretches you
squish it squish butt-ugly we've been
making to the hero
hey everybody we got a whole bunch of
new blasts to break down and there's a
bunch of stuff in the episode they don't
include in the promo it was pitched to
me as a council of Wells episode which
is basically them doing Rick and Morty
doing Marvel so I'll explain the Marvel
Rick and Morty Easter eggs but this
promo mostly focuses on Ralph's Dib knee
getting his first version of the comic
book costume so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything they'll be giveaway stuff
at the end of the video too but just to
start with the actual footage that they
drop so they're mostly doing this night
at the museum style like you see them
getting thrown through walls here things
coming to life the dinosaur comes to
life behind them the metahuman that
they're trying to track down is another
one of the bus metahumans they can
animate inanimate objects so you get the
idea they could he could probably bring
pretty much anything in the museum to
life like you see something standing
behind the flash here that looks kind of
like a caveman that's just walking
around that's probably also from this
museum but the reason for the council of
wealth in the episode is is because they
have a problem that they can't solve on
their own it might have something to do
with this Night at the Museum plotline
that's going on between Barry and
elongated man but basically Cisco is the
one that has the idea hey we have a
whole bunch of smart Harrison wells out
in the multiverse why don't we pull them
together so they form their own council
of ricks but I know a lot of you have
asked why don't they do a Council of
Barry's like why don't you just get a
ton of the Flash's together and I think
that's just because from a story
standpoint they have a problem writing
that like literally in the writers room
you bring a bunch of the most powerful
men together it just becomes really hard
for them to face a challenge that's
worthwhile like it would just be them
solving all the problems on the show
locking up all the metahumans on earth
one and the show would be over in like
three episodes and that'd be the end of
the flash but I'm still holding out hope
for a giant team flash team up in a
future season like where you have the
full flash family like Jay Garrick Jesse
quick Wally West they're all teaming up
to fight somebody like the reverse flash
but in the meantime it makes sense
Harrison wells is still the smartest
person on the team you go get a bunch of
him and put them together to solve
whatever problem they have so they built
their multiverse thing
tank so obviously we're getting into
thinker territory the next episode after
this is called therefore I am as in
cogito ergo soon Latin for I think
therefore I am so like it's a really big
thinker episode so they've really only
been dedicating the last like 30 seconds
and beginning 30 seconds of episodes to
thinkers stuff this season this is when
they really start to push into that
storyline they kind of did the same
thing last season with Savitt are where
you got the reveal in episode 6 thence
avatar proceeds to kick Barry's ass in a
big action set piece during episode 7
and then then they really start focusing
on The Saboteur plotline so I'm assuming
the same sort of paradigm this year with
the thinker like they started to learn
about it they talked about Deveaux at
the beginning of last week's episode so
if you're waiting for the real storyline
to start happening
that's when but I'm expecting the
crossover episode to be sort of a break
in that that tends to be its own thing
it'll be like a four hour movie so by
crossover videos we'll be a little bit
different but I'll try to differentiate
the crossover storyline from what like
the main storyline is on all the other
TV shows yet I have been getting a lot
of requests to do catch-up videos for
the other TV shows before the crossover
episode but don't worry that's a couple
weeks away so no big deal we'll worry
about that when we get a little bit
closer but if you don't watch Rick and
Morty the council of ricks is something
that's actually inspired by the council
of reeds which is a Marvel thing which
is basically just a bunch of versions of
Reed Richards that got together to form
a multiverse think tank so really the
challenge of the episode almost becomes
secondary to the fun of seeing all the
different versions of that character
that's the whole reason why you do
something like that just the joy of
trying to figure out what each of those
characters are inspired by in the way
Tom Cavanagh said it is that some of
them are inspired by comic book
characters some of them are based on
some real-life Hollywood tropes but he
did say this funny thing at a Comic Con
panel a couple years ago where he has
this goal to get the number of different
versions of Harrison wells that he plays
before the show ends to get to triple
digits so just imagine that by the time
we get to season 8 season 9 they'll be
like a hundred different versions of
Harrison wells we'll see how close he
gets to that number of course the
easiest way to do that is just a
do a Council of wells episode once per
season but if you haven't seen that Rick
and Morty episode the last big council
of ricks episode was season 3 episode 7
so I'll link that video at the end of
this because it is one of the best
episodes of the season oh sorry I was
expecting Rick partner lesson one rookie
expect the unexpected now get in but I
just found out that I'm gonna be seeing
Justice League next Monday the embargo
is up on Wednesday so that's when my
non-spoilery review will post so far
things are looking ok but I'll be really
interested to see what the movie
actually looks like and Jason Momoa
confirmed that there is a post-credits
scene so I'll do a couple of Justice
League videos in the next couple of days
but I won't actually be seeing the movie
till next Monday as of me posting this
video but if you didn't see it there was
a bunch of new details about what's
going on with the Bruce wayne/batman of
the flash and arrow verse so I might do
that tomorrow but I have some new
Superman Justice League that I'll post
later tonight there's a whole bunch of
marvel and DC stuff happening in the
next couple of days so I'll try to get
through it as fast as possible but I'll
be posting updates in that top pin
comment where I usually put
announcements so just check the comments
for that congratulations to hit Wanda
you're the latest winner please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for last night's flash
episode and you can click here for brand
new Justice League thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight